hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
wine month slash world's okay s mom /
whatever you want to call me I don't I'm
here quick hair update I put some blue
over it it's rinsing out pink kind of
doing this like hybrid muted unicorn in
the winter color and I like it I'm
actually very happy with it right now so
at the end of every episode we gave you
guys a number to text with questions
ideas for future topics stuff that you
want me to talk about and it's become
very clear that you guys love to talk
about sex so tonight's topic things I
wish I knew about sex or things I wish
I'd known about sex whatever is
grammatically correct I'm not I haven't
been in school in a long time I don't
remember
so first sex means something different
to everyone when you are choosing a
partner to have sex with it's so
important that you both are on the same
page I've learned from a lot of trial
and error
you can't like go into a sexual
experience feeling a certain way and
expecting the other person to feel
exactly the same you have to be very
clear with the other person and have a
very clear understanding of what you're
both looking for before you go into
something like that for example I am a
very emotionally charged person for me
sex is an emotional act and it's
something that like I need to have
feeling behind for a lot of people it's
kind of just like for fun both ways of
looking at it are totally fair and valid
but if I were to have sex with someone
who's just doing it for fun I would end
up severely hurt I for sure was very
naive about what if a guy wants to sleep
with me then he likes me and wants to
date me and that's not always the case
and had I know not I would have saved
myself a lot of hurt I think if
everybody goes into sex saying like this
is what I'm doing it for and they're
very explicit about that it's a way more
enjoyable experience I think the
conversation of what you're looking for
needs to happen well before your clothes
are off once the clothes come off then
it's just like it's like you've gotten
to the top of the roller coaster and
you're like teetering on the edge and
you're like wow like I can't I just
gotta do
because it doesn't need to be an awkward
conversation it can just be like a hey
by the way like this is what I'm looking
for and the more convicted you are and
like what you want the better it's gonna
be and I think that conversation happens
less and less as you grow and learn
you'll be able to pick up on what the
other person is looking for very easily
so to quote the Backstreet Boys quit
playing games with my heart it's my
heart my heart I'm fully evolved in just
like that
embarrassing dorky mom who's just like
hey kids how the selfies come in I just
kicked that's our next sex is a two-way
street I went into my sex life not
realizing that I deserved an orgasm I
almost thought that there were something
wrong with me because I could not
achieve that through just like straight
up I don't
penetration I went so long not realizing
that that's normal and like that's okay
I wish that my partners had no nut and
it recognized that like oh I might have
to do a little bit extra to make sure
that Hannah gets something out of this
and then I finally met someone who was
like no like that's really messed up if
it's just good for me and not you and
they like really cared and put in the
time and put in like the effort to make
sure that we both got something out of
it so don't always assume that your
partner is just gonna know what you need
and like be that giving person it's okay
to ask for what you want it is a very
fair as a woman to expect to get just as
much enjoyment and pleasure out of sex
as a man women's orgasms are just as
important as men's so next your number
does not define you the number of people
you've slept with doesn't define sexual
adequacy and you should not feel badly
about yourself for that number so if
your number is exceptionally low that's
fine you could have five times as much
experience because you've maybe been in
a long-term relationship and just had
one sexual partner and like really
evolved over time and if you have a high
number of sexual partners that doesn't
mean they're promiscuous the sex is like
an unlabeled box of chocolates so you're
like digging through it like I just want
the caramel one aisle thug that's
coconut [ __ ] all right that's a
raspberry cream I hate that and then you
finally get the caramel and for some
people half it's on the first try but
for some of us takes a few bites to find
who I'm looking for
I'm trying metaphors I I'm trying okay
like I can't always find the best
metaphor and last sex is a learning
process when I first started having sex
I felt like I needed to know all the
answers I needed to know everything
about myself and everything I wanted
that's never gonna happen no matter how
old you are no matter how much sex
you've had it's always gonna be a
learning process maybe when you're like
21 you're doing something and you like
it about 31 it's a totally different
ballgame like
your sex life is something that grows
with you so for people who are just
starting out and like trying to figure
things out you don't need to know all
the answers you don't need to know the
end-all be-all of like what you want or
what's good and what you want to do
because it's gonna change and that's the
beauty of life and for example in ten
years you're gonna look back and realize
that you didn't know anything about sex
so in ten years
future ten year Hannah shut up stop
preaching about the facts cuz you don't
know [ __ ] hope future Hannah's doing
okay I hope you like still drink wine
and enjoy yourself
future hannah has silver hair takes no
[ __ ] from anybody I gotta stop taking
[Music]
this is getting weird that's all I got
for today I'm Hannah your friendly
neighborhood wine mom / world's okay
it's mom / whatever the heck I am Miss
Hannah on the couch if there's a topic
you want me to talk about in a future
episode or any other question you have
regarding this topic leave it in the
comments or as always you can text me I
don't always respond to all of them but
I read every single one because I love
seeing what you guys want me to talk
about and at the end of the day sex is
great but if all else fails there's
always ice cream which is what I'm about
to go get right about now till next time
[Music]
no burp in the silencer
I don't have a one not one
[Music]